was wir jetzt allerdings noch fehlt ist
eine beauty magica hallo luca kannst du
mal auf die sendung beauty and the word
reagieren auf prosieben läuft die die es
mega witzig ich weiß nicht was das ist
hab dann mal gegoogelt und diesen
artikel dazu gesehen namen zickige
frauen und dreckigen nord zum
fremdschämen diese tv-shows 2020 einfach
nur peinlich aber überzeugen uns jetzt
selbst davon und schauen uns
dementsprechend die erste folge von bio
dienten nathan jetzt zeige ich euch was
da alles drin zu uns aufs wort
willkommen bei beauty and denn dieser
luxus villa auf initiative zwar als
deutlich dazu oder als beauty in dieser
luxusvilla auf ibiza trifft eitelkeit
auf einsamkeit okay jetzt müssen wir die
längen alu cross stellte oder winzerin
bis schlagersängerin
ach so das sind schon gestandene größen
mehr oder weniger die daran teilnehmen
für mich ist eine frau will ich muss
direkt los da einfach um laut und dann
einmal laute buchstaben und ich dachte
finger weg
ich hoffe dass die noch mal checken nur
schwer ist eigentlich ist eine gute idee
zu sein
[Musik]
also ich glaube die wollen die klischees
ja auch so ein bisschen mit dieser
sendung bedienen und prosieben weiß ganz
genau hey das ist jetzt kein politischer
wille aller house of cards dem wir
gerade produzieren sondern alt beauty an
den ort so eine sendung zum lachen
bisher ist auf jeden fall auch eine
sendung zum lachen
[Musik]
ich habe mich eingesetzt dann bin ich
nicht im klassenzimmer lauf aber jetzt
rolle ich einfach durch mein zimmer dass
die unpassenden nerds dazu auch
schüchterne sonderlinge für die echte
beauties fremdkörper sind war klar dass
die nerds halt wirklich wieder somit
standardmäßig weißen tennissocken in
sandalen sonnencreme und die bibel und
brille dargestellt werden
die gerne klamotten von meinem vater
ok los mit schmuddel look der o mein
gott der gerade so aus wie der professor
von house of cards des geldes
ich habe ahnung von seiner elf
den ohren wer schafft den sprung von der
knalltüte zur siegertyp
es war entspannt das allerdings mit sich
selbst redet aber das impliziert ja
quasi dass es wirklich am ende auf einen
gewinner gibt also es ist jetzt nicht so
wie bei true to handle auf das sich ja
auch derzeit auf meinem kanal so ein
bisschen reagiere das am ende halt alle
irgendwie zusammenhalts gewinner
beziehungsweise verlierer dastehen und
die teilen sich das preisgeld wurde war
aber hier ist es anscheinend wirklich
sonne ausscheide
falls das in irgendeiner hinsicht sind
ergibt aber irgendwie ergibt ja heute
allgemein gar nicht siegen ungleiche
paare erkenntnis dass manchmal zieht
sich auch gegensätzliches an und das ist
wirklich ganz spannend okay
also wir haben auch hier wieder eine
pädagogische schwerpunkte
es soll vermittelt werden haye
nur weil die ganz andere interessen
haben als die heißt es nicht gleich zwei
plus magneten die können nicht nur
sondern kann auch er menschen ob der
schlussendlich nachher wirklich der fall
sein wird bleibt abzuwarten dabei
gemerkt dass frauen eigentlich sozusagen
menschen sind die wir alle erkenntnis
des jahres
rost nobelpreis verdient also jetzt
während der staffel beauty um den mord
aufgefallen dass frauen wirklich
menschen sind was geht denn auch die
ganz jungen verhängt und sich
entschuldigt und ganz kurz
wir sind bei minute 3 und die komplette
sendung wurde quasi schon gespoilert
welches paar erkämpft sich 50.000 euro
welcher nerd holt sich am ende das make
over für den start in ein völlig neues
leben moment das wirklich ein wettkampf
und anscheinend müssen sich dann
irgendwie die beauties und nerds in
paare zusammen tun so bleiben sie dann
für die ganze sendung und das paar das
am ende gewinnt bekommt 50.000 euro und
der nerd bekommt dann zudem noch eine
umwandlung
ja hätte ich auch nötig irgendwo im
nirgendwo auf ibiza hat express rollt
richtung abenteuer geiler bulli befinden
sich 72
[Musik]
die koffer hat sich auch ich sehe mich
da schon bricht hier so besitzt kommen
an bord befinden sich sieben zumeist
ungekürzte liebes looser und gamer noch
keinen gemeinsamen endgegner frauen
wie sehr wollte klischees bedienen
prosieben ja wahnsinnig unangenehm
weiblich umgang habe ich so oder so
wenig sehen von mutter oma usw
neuland für mich okay für den frommen
stream war bisher enthaltsamkeit
angesagt hat janina wenn er da der bibel
mitgenommen hat all das könnt ihr mir
noch nie hat er wenn paar sekunden
später eigentlich im ferienlager tätig
wo ich bin auch schon mal sommer wird
viele frauen teilen muss alter aber dass
ehrenhaft ich dachte jetzt wirklich
irgendwie das wäre ja komm wir haben die
gamer oder noch eine verkleiden war als
jesus unmäßig wie bei toto händel hat
man ja auch schon jesus look alike typen
dabei aber er ist wirklich priester
fällt auch ins ferienlager und so finde
ich auf jeden fall stark also die
vernetzt zu einer villa
ich will ich euch sehe ich für die villa
sehen
oder welcher auch gerade gern
stattdessen schillig in köln bei regen
die beauties stehen schon parat die
wünsche haben selbstbewusste traumfrauen
dann erleben zwischen partys klicks und
glamour für ok also wir haben
komplette gegensätzliche heute am start
ich bin 100 prozent live
okay vielleicht möchten sie ja ich sehe
gut aus
ich habe zwar nichts gravierend aber ich
sehe gut aus hey ich bin die celina
freunde jetzt aber selbstverständlich
wieder nicht beleidigend gemeint aber
ich habe auch zu beginn gesagt die
sendung wird gewünscht die sendung ist
auch kritisch allerdings war ich jetzt
statt also ich finde es mega mega
unterhaltsam findet auch ein link zu der
landing-page heißt es so von beauty and
the word und in der beschreibung könnt
ihr euch doch selber einfach die
komplette folge anschauen wenn er bock
drauf habt und ich habe auch selbst
wahrscheinlich nichts gegen die
kandidaten wieder gegen die nerds noch
gegen die beauties es ist einfach nur
meine reaktion alle sind cool
miteinander
das verspricht doch einige tiefsinnige
gespräche mit anschließend kriegen
[Musik]
ja
mir geht's nicht wenn man einfach mal
creed war aufregung völlig neue nicht
versehentlich meisten ich weiß wo ich
war schon mal da hab ich
das wichtigste die intelligenz damit ich
mich mit ihm überhaupt verstehen kann ja
sich ähnlich bei mir sind eleganz auch
ziemlich wichtig allerdings ist meine
intelligenz nicht vorhanden von daher
ist es dann auch wieder nebensächlich
eine wahl haben die nerds allerdings nur
falls sich mehr als eine beauty für sie
erwärmen kann verstehe ich das auto auch
die haben eine band dazwischen okay
jetzt wird's interessant ladies and
gentlemen nördlichen allererster stelle
ein langweiliger typ das stinkt
ja jeder jeder nerd stinkt einfach er
trägt auf jeden fall ein pullunder
socken in sandalen und auf jeden fall
eine bruegel immer voll okay das
beispiel jetzt gerade die denn das sorgt
mit seinen damals hatten aber ja also es
ist halt wirklich so dieses klischee
bild was man sich halt einfach
vorstellen ist halt wirklich sagen da in
tennissocken kurze hose die allerdings
immer viel zu kurzes dann meistens halt
noch mit so rosen träger die festgemacht
sind über dem hemd von hollis damals
irgendwie auch noch irgendwie nur so
dass hier geht's und halbes t shirt ist
dann natürlich brille ungemach tat um
gemachte haare am stinken langweilig und
grundsätzlich schlau nur am magic spielt
und new world of warcraft dann in der
nacht das ist kein standard bild was man
von einem nerd und das wollten natürlich
auch ganz klar hier bedienen ich
persönlich finde dann nichts schlimmes
dran ich find jeder mensch sollte so
leben sollte so sein und sollte die
vorlieben haben ja halt haben möchte
allerdings wissen wir glaube ich alle
dass das hier selbstverständlich eine
sendung ist und wir schauen weiter die
nerds treten nacheinander vor die
beauties an der schönheit darf sich
einen passenden aussuchen werden sich
mehrere liegt die entscheidung beim
nörten nacheinander
ich dachte jetzt einfach die wand fällt
und andere geht es los auf war dann audi
ag wahrscheinlich hätte nicht so ein
grosses übereinander hergefallen seien
aber ich dachte dass es so wird und
nicht dass sie sich einzeln vorstellen
es geht es mit zauber kartensammler die
union kommt der zaubergarten schau mal
wer sich für den dion entscheidet ich
bin der die unheilig habe über 100.000
magic karten mir jetzt allerdings noch
fehlt ist eine beauty magic hat die
orden du hast du deine ansprüche auf
wunsch bestellt ich wusste was auf uns
zukommt als die nutzern rauskramen
dachte ich okay das ist echt krass
entwickeln ja bisher nur die anrufe bild
für die götter hier gerade und die alle
gewesen
und dann dachte ich na gut dann halt
nicht
die daten auch sony wird er jährlich
geben mit tränen aus den reactions wenn
ihr da allerdings überhaupt bock drauf
hat meine lieben freunde lassen einen
daumen hoch oder dem video hier das
schaffen wir 50.000 like das wird mir
auf jeden fall zeigen hey luca wir haben
bock auf den zweiten teil beauty ende
nördlich so witzig diese sorgen
allerdings befinden wir uns jetzt auch
schon im auto meine lieben freunde wenn
ihr noch keinen trainer luxus sein also
meinen kanal noch nicht abonniert habe
dann klickt unbedingt ganz schnell auf
diese smiley dass es kostenlos und
verpasst keine videos mehr und wenn ich
schon aber dennoch die glocke dann
bekommt eine benachrichtigung sobald ich
etwas neues hoch laden und hier ist
video verdient was auf meinem zweikanal
gestern online gegangen ist mega lustig
neues video mit sandra also check geht